they're finding folks for cursing in
Arlington Virginia and banning dead
people from driving in New Jersey this
month nanny is staying in the garden
state where anti-smoking zealotry has
reached an absurd new low look we all
agree that smoking is the worst thing
humanity has ever conceived course the
war confederate flag or crocs so you
think New Jersey would welcome a company
that wanted to conduct research that
might actually help people kick that
awful awful habit trouble as a research
company can't conduct the research
because it's prohibited by an
anti-smoking law New Jersey smoke-free
air act claims to make people healthier
by banning smoking in most indoor public
places even labs that want to study the
health effects of traditional cigarettes
compared to vapor based ecigarettes but
here comes state senator jennifer beck
who's introduced a bill that would
exempt medical and scientific labs from
the smoke-free air act well no that
seems like something that everybody can
rally around or maybe not because it
turns out a major anti-smoking
organization opposes the bill because it
would permit more indoor smoking they
can do the study outside just like
everybody else has to says Karen
Blumenfeld executive director of gasp
the Global Advisors on smoke-free policy
so to sum up smoking is so bad that we
should ban as much of it as possible
including smoking that might help more
people quit smoking got it falling in it
a month on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and watch out for busybodies
minding your own business